well welcome back to peacefulness for
those who think cancel culture is real
no further than Britain strictures have
mistress Catherine bubble Singh she runs
the Michaela Community School a deprived
part of North London the school focuses
on discipline and manners it's called
boot camp discipline detentions given
for lateness for eye rolling for tutting
for forgetting to bring in a pen quite
right too you might think not everyone
shares that you've said to me you really
want to be at this school you've said to
me that you understand why the rules are
here and why you need to behave yourself
I can't fix this
Mr Bullock can't fix it
who's gonna fix it
you're the only one who can fix it
your mom and dad be so disappointed
well Catherine bubble saying I'm done
thank you for coming in it's great to to
have you on the show
um you've been at the center of news
again because you invited Jordan
Peterson you know I interviewed
yesterday and we're running it in full
next week we're going to run in a moment
on a few minutes a little bit more of
that interview about you and the visit
attitude of the school which led to you
having people report you to the police
for hate crimes simply for allowing
Jordan Peterson to come to your school
which says everything you need to know
about the absurdity of modern society
and Council culture we'll come to that
part of this in a moment first of all
you're the tiger head mistress what does
that mean what is your teaching style if
you were to Define it simply well we
believe that the adults should be the
authority in the room the parents and
teachers should be in charge
um and that means leading the learning
it means desks being in rows and the
children looking to the teacher who who
leads the way
um it means high standards of discipline
so people think oh you know I must hate
children because
um I and then I must walk down the
corridors with whips and chains when
when actually you know I'm in school
every morning at 6 45 and I don't do
that because I hate them it's because I
love them and I know what they need to
be able to succeed I don't need phones
no well and that's another thing so we
wouldn't allow them phones but in fact
we go more than just we don't just ban
them in school we strongly encourage
parents not to give their children
Smartphones at all you can give your
child a brick phone uh you can still
ring them you can still text them but
they're not getting unsupervised access
to the internet do you practice you
practice tough love teaching for one of
a better phrase yeah why has it
attracted any controversy I mean your
results are outstanding yes you take a
lot of very deprived kids yes who don't
have any privilege in their lives yeah
you just had 98 pass rate in your gcses
I think yeah many a star level so you're
doing an amazing job yes helping these
kids achieve their potential and yet
there are people out there who'll be
listening to this now and going this
sounds horrible terrible This Woman's
evil yeah how have we got to this place
well I I think people think it's mean to
give children detentions and to
discipline them but the thing is is that
if you don't do that then the children
will just been out of control yes and
I'll tell you what's mean it's living
your life uh functionally enumerate and
functionally illiterate and there are
lots of people who end up doing that
because school didn't do the right job
by them and hold their standards high
for them
are too many schools just too soft and
is the softness coming from being
terrified of this new culture again
where people say if you do anything to
do with discipline then you're bullying
you're racist whatever the excuse they
can think of to play the victim they
play it hard and teachers just get
scared they don't want to have to
operate in that environment
I don't think that they're just scared I
think all of our society really uh
encourages us to think like this so in
order for a head teacher to to do things
properly in my view you've got to be
quite Brave to stand up to the Mob I
mean for instance I invited Jordan
Peterson to come and just walk around
the school and see the school just as we
have 600 other visitors who come and see
the schools of all different Persuasions
politically and socially and everything
else exactly because you believe
presumably that actually the best
education is to have a wide range of
different people with different views
yeah but you know this is completely
going out of fashion in our education
system yeah universities now if you
deviate even one iota to the right you
get no platform you get shamed there are
protests going on yeah this kind of woke
cancer culture is out of control yeah
and so that's why as a head teacher
you've got to be quite Brave and that's
I think it's a little unreasonable in a
way to ask that of of ordinary people
who are just trying to do a job teachers
my own teachers for instance I have to
really support them emotionally because
they come to work at our school and
their friends question their decision to
do that they wonder what they're doing
are they actually do they not know who
they really are
um and and I have to support my teachers
and they say well how can I convince my
friends that I'm not a bad person I mean
this is completely insane I know you're
having to to comfort your staff who are
working in a highly driven motivated
environment which is successful with
happy successful children coming out
better than they go in and you're having
to help your staff because they're being
treated so badly by their own friendship
groups because they're working in this
environment and it's nuts I know and the
thing is is that those people say that
they want to help deprive children and
here we are transforming their lives and
yet they're highly critical and there's
some of them who would really like to
see us shut down